I heard this one rumor that you live in  a military building like an an old  military complex that you sort of took  over and that's where you live and I  want to believe that's true because it's  one of the coolest things I've ever  heard is it true it is true and thank  you for bringing it up because now even  more people will come to the house to  say hello but yeah I bought an old Air  Force Base it's a former top-secret Air  Force Base and it has an incredible  history it sits in the Hollywood Hills  if you need my address I'll send it to  you after the show you could come by  yeah I do yeah  it must be I mean what a great idea you  live in this does there are there cool  steel doors that can close there  actually are yeah yeah our former vaults  in the place that are labeled like  top-secret access and yeah it's a piece  of history it's pretty cool that's so  great  you